ils n'étaient pas nombreux ce mercredi
devant l'enseigné monoprix de versailles
pourtant depuis un an ces militants de
l'association l214 manifeste pour
inciter le groupe à ne plus vendre deux
de poules élevées en cage selon eux
leurs conditions de vie sont indignes
le groupe milite pour un élevage
uniquement au sol ou en plein air un
fonctionnement déjà adoptée en allemagne
ou en belgique
alors qu'en france 80 % des poules sont
élevées en batterie c'est pas juste une
volonté d'une association de protection
animale isolé mais que leur clientèle
est d'accord avec cette démarche refuse
elle aussi les oeufs de poules élevées
en cage pour sont des conditions
ignobles de vie pour les poules et que
vraiment dans une société évolue et on
devrait on ne devrait pas accepter ce
type de production du tout c'est
vraiment le minimum qu'on pourrait
accorder aux animaux voient la pétition
lancée par l'association l214 a déjà
réuni plus de 25 mille signatures
suite à des discussions avec
l'association l'enseigne monoprix a
réagi en retirant de ses rayons les
oeufs de poules élevées en cage de sa
marque distributeur dans une trentaine
de magasins de la région lyonnaise
une évolution sous forme de test se
terminera fin décembre